[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco deve esser stato più o meno così o
almeno così me lo sono immaginato che la
prima donna che riuscì a intrappolare il
fuoco
entrando nella sua caverna magari creò
un po meno un po più di stupore un po
più di meraviglia e forse anche un po
più di paura nelle persone nei suoi
familiari che la incontravano una donna
che intrappola il fuoco certo non c'è
una verità scientifica non ci sono prove
di questa cosa
però a me piace immaginare che si adatta
proprio così
e di certo non sarebbe stato l'unico
momento in cui una donna ha portato
l'umanità a fare un balzo nel futuro
e poi non vogliamo mica immaginare che
un uomo magari poi un cavernicolo
immaginatevi avesse la grazia per fare
una cosa così delicata e così anche
pericolosa come intrappolare il fuoco
dicevo non sarebbe stata la prima volta
che una donna nella storia dell'umanità
e non serve non è neanche l'ultima che
appunto una donna ci conduce per mano
nel nel futuro
l'ultima la più recente se volete
l'azione che sta compiendo una ragazzina
svedese di 16 anni ma questa è un'altra
e un'altra storia e le donne da sempre
nella storia dell'umanità soprattutto
nei momenti di maggiore buio di maggiore
tenebre hanno preso si sono fatte carico
di tutto il peso del genere umano e
l'hanno condotto fuori fuori dalle
tenebre basti pensare per esempio al
ruolo delle delle staffette partigiane
durante la guerra di resistenza al
nazifascismo oppure alle tante
tantissime eroina e di cui è costellata
la storia dell'umanità anche in
agricoltura le donne hanno sempre avuto
un ruolo importante a iniziare dall'idea
stessa dalla concezione stessa di
agricoltura i libri ci parlano di donne
che erano raccoglitrici erano accudivano
la prole e probabilmente però proprio
queste competenze di cura queste
competenze di hanno portate poi magari a
fare le prime esperienze di
addomesticamento di specie vegetali
oppure di le prime esperienze di
allevamento di animali ai fini
produttivi e ho parlato di progresso di
donne che ci accompagnano nel progresso
e non sempre nella storia alla parola
progresso poi è corrisposta una realtà
un reale balzo in avanti e soprattutto
un balzo in avanti sostenibile per il
genere umano e per e per il pianeta
pensate per esempio alla rivoluzione
verde anni 60 anni 70 che cosa è stata e
quello che ha portato in agricoltura
l'uso intensivo di fitofarmaci di
concimi chimici di sintesi e con l'uso
anche smodato se volete della risorsa
idrica e l'impiego di macchine
fortemente energivore ebbe di chi fu
questa idea geniale di un uomo richard
barlow non è che aveva delle cattive
intenzioni avesse delle cattive
intenzioni però semplicemente non era
una donna cioè non aveva quelle tre
quelle che io chiamo le tre grazie
agricole e che sono corrispondono alla
generazione è la capacità di generare
alla capacità di conservare quindi la
conservazione e alla capacità di educare
io vorrei presentarvele per farvi capire
anche meglio di che cosa sto parlando
queste tre grazie ovvero voglio
presentarvi proprio il loro volto il
loro volto locale e attuale nulla
esclude anzi sicuramente in altre epoche
storiche ed altri lati tutte le altre
latitudini
queste tre grazie a assumono sembianze
diverse
e allora parto da lei lei è generazione
lavora alla banca del germoplasma della
regione campania
e stata quella che è riuscita dobbiamo
dire grazie alle xi un san marzano sa
ancora di pomodoro il il san marzano si
era perso proprio per le necessità
dell'industria agroalimentare si erano
persi i sapori e non attraverso tecniche
di laboratorio sofisticate tecniche di
laboratorio
oppure attraverso procedure complesse di
genoma editing ma facendo semplicemente
quello che i contadini e le contadine di
tutto il mondo fanno da migliaia di anni
cioè lavorando sugli incroci stagione
dopo stagione incrocio dopo incluso
quindi un lavoro molto lento è riuscita
a riprodurre le caratteristiche del san
marzano che era stato che era stato
perso io penso che il suo lavoro il
valore del suo lavoro stia
essenzialmente in due aspetti uno è
quello di ricordare a tutti quanti noi
proprio quello che dicevo prima cioè che
i contadini da sempre hanno fatto
selezione però nella storia questa
selezione si basava sulla capacità sulle
caratteristiche organolettiche quindi di
gusto e di sapore e sulle
caratteristiche nutrizionali di un
prodotto negli ultimi 50 anni invece la
selezione che naturalmente non è stata
poi solamente frutto di incroci ma anche
di altre di altre tecniche è stata
guidata dalle necessità
dell'agroindustria quindi abbiamo
prodotti sempre più standardizzati
prodotti sempre più compatibili al
processo agro industriale e quindi non
abbiamo più
il san marzano non avevamo più su
ammazzano fino a che generazione non non
fosse intervenuta con il suo lavoro
l'altro aspetto molto importante è
quella di assicurare alle future
generazioni sapori gusti consistenze che
se no sarebbero state perse insieme alla
specie vegetale che le aveva determinate
se ci pensate però non diamo la giusta
riconoscenza a chi riporta in vita in
qualche modo specie vegetali che si sono
perse pensate se oggi uno scienziato ci
riportasse in vita un cucciolo di mammut
sicuramente questa
notizia avrebbe un eco mediatico
notevolissimo invece lei che ha
riportato in vita il san marzano neanche
un piccolo busto nell'aula di
orticoltura della facoltà di agraria no
niente e magari neanche conosciamo il
suo nome invece stasera e proprio
l'occasione per dire grazie anche a
generazione
lei invece conservazione è un assise ver
che cosa fa gira il mondo è in cerca di
comunità remote o anche di piccoli di
singoli agricoltori che magari però
hanno conservato qualche seme oppure
hanno piantato hanno ancora qualche
albero di frutto antico si fa regalare
questi semi e poi torna sempre alla sua
lucania dove poi prova a moltiplicare la
varietà e la biodiversità che le hanno
che le hanno donato e lei è una donna
del sud italia
il sud italia è una dei è uno dei
territori del mondo con la più alto il
più alto indice di biodiversità
coltivata spesso si fa confusione tra
biodiversità tukur e biodiversità
coltivata immaginate la mazzoni
all'amazzonia naturalmente è ricca di
biodiversità ma non è ricca di
biodiversità coltivata invece una terra
dove ci sono passati greci romani arabi
fenici cartaginesi normanni africani in
questa terra
il sud italia la biodiversità coltivata
è una delle più ricche del mondo è una
terra una delle terre con la
biodiversità coltivata maggiore quindi
la biodiversità coltivata ha bisogno di
una storia ed è la prova della della
convivenza tra i popoli
e la prova che la politica dei porti
chiusi non ha alcun senso e la prova
biologica che l'incrocio lo stare
insieme ha sempre portato una maggiore
ricchezza ci ha sempre dato qualcosa di
più e queste storie conservazione è
sempre stata molto appassionata che cosa
fa quando
visita una comunità si fa mettere
qualche seme in un vasetto una parte li
lascia nel vasetto per raccontare quella
storia per continuare a raccontare
quella storia
l'altra la semina e da dal seminare
storie nascono sempre nuove storie
l'ultima che vi voglio presentare è
educazione
non vi nascondo che è un po la mia
preferita anche perché senza educazione
probabilmente non esisterebbe libero
neanche le altre due grazie agricole lei
oltre a coltivare il suo terreno cucina
e insegna insegna ai contadini ad essere
dei contadini ma non solo a chi già fa
il contadino a chi lo vuole diventare a
tutti a tutti quanti noi perché è
estremamente convinta che se l'uomo per
procurarsi il cibo da millenni ha sempre
coltivato molto piantato alberi da
frutta
allora qualcosa deve essere rimasto
appiccicato al dna di ognuno di noi
lei prova a tirare fuori questa memoria
atavica se volete educazione ci ricorda
che il mondo l'abbiamo in eredità dai
nostri figli ci ricorda che non esiste
una globalizzazione delle merci o meglio
se la globalizzazione delle merci
diventa solo globalizzazione delle
disuguaglianze se non porta anche con sé
la cultura e la storia che c'è dietro un
prodotto e l'indice che è appunto
abbiamo da costruire nuove e future
generazioni di contadini e
questo era il simbolo di educazione
quindi le donne il ruolo delle donne in
agricoltura da sempre le donne hanno ci
hanno dato la possibilità di guardare al
nostro futuro sono state le nostre guide
in mi in tutti i posti del mondo in
migliaia di anni le l'agricoltura locale
l'agricoltura familiare l'agricoltura di
prossimità ha sfamato migliaia migliaia
di persone sfama ancora migliaia e
migliaia di persone per cui in un tempo
come il nostro in cui la natura sembra
volerci presentare il conto in cui si
parla c'è chi parla ragione di collasso
eco sistemico della più grande della più
grande catastrofe climatica che si può
che si può avere da da qui a poco io
penso che tutti quanti noi dovremmo
affidarci con fiducia alle donne hanno
sempre dimostrato che sono capaci di
portarci fuori dalle tenebre
dobbiamo guardarle amarle imparare da
loro e soprattutto riporre il le sorti
del pianeta nelle loro mani
[Musica]